strike them we break away from that to
take you to the u.s president joe biden
speaking on his new framework for his
social spending plan
turn the climate crisis into an
opportunity and put us on a path not
only to compete but to win the economic
competition
for the 21st century against china and
every other major country in the world
it's fiscally responsible
it's fully paid for
17 nobel prize winners in economics have
said it will lower the inflationary
pressures on the economy
and over the next 10 years
it will not add to the deficit at all it
will actually reduce the deficit
according to economists
i want to thank my colleagues in the
congress for the leadership
we spent hours and hours and hours over
months and months working on this
no one got everything they wanted
including me
but that's what compromise is
that's consensus
and that's what i ran on
i've long said compromise and consensus
are the only way to get big things done
in a democracy
important things done for the country
i know it's hard
i know how deeply people feel about the
things that they fight for
but this framework includes historic
investments in our nation and on our
people
any single element of this framework
would fundamentally view would be viewed
as a fundamental change in america
taking together
they're truly consequential
i'll have more to say after i return
from the critical meetings in europe
this week
but for now let me lay out a few points
first
we face and i know i apologize for
saying this again we face we face an
inflection point as a nation
for most of the 20th century we led the
world by a significant margin because we
invested in our people
not only our roads and our highways and
our bridges but in our people
and our families
we didn't just build an interstate
highway system we built a highway to the
sky
we invested to win the space race and we
won
we're also among the first to provide
access to free education
for all americans beginning back in the
late 1800s that decision alone to invest
in our children and their families was a
major part
of why we were able to lead the world
for much of the 20th century
but somewhere along the way
we stopped investing in ourselves
investing in our people
america is still the largest economy in
the world
we still have the most productive
workers and most innovative minds in the
world
but we've risked losing our edge as a
nation
our infrastructure used to be rated the
best in the world today
according to the world economic forum we
ranked 13th
in the world
we used to lead the world in educational
achievement
now the organization for economic
cooperation and development ranks
america 35th
out of the 37 major countries when it
comes to investing in early childhood
education and care
we know how our children start
impact significantly and how they'll
finish we can't be competitive in the
21st century global economy if we can
continue this slide
that's why i've said all along
we need to build america from the bottom
up in the middle out
not from the top down
with the trickle-down economics that's
always failed us i can't think of a
single time when the middle class has
done well that the wealthy haven't done
very well
i think many times including now when
the wealthy the super wealthy do very
well
and the middle class don't do well
that's why i propose the investments
congress is now considering
in two critical pieces of legislation
positions i ran on as president
positions i announced one i
laid out in a joint session of congress
what my economic agenda was
these are not about left versus right
or moderate versus progressive or
anything else that pits americans
against one another
this is about competitiveness versus
complacency
competitiveness versus complacency it's
about expanding opportunity not
opportunity to deny it's about leading
the world
or letting the world pass us by
today
with my democratic colleagues we have a
framework
for my build back better initiative
and here's how it will fundamentally
change the lives of millions of people
for the better
millions of you are in the so-called
sandwich generation
who feel financially squeezed
by raising a child and caring for an
aging parent
about 820 000 seniors in america
and people with disabilities
have applied
for medicaid
and they're on a waiting list right now
to get home care
they need some help they don't have to
be put they're not being kicked out of
their homes
but they need a little help getting
around
having their meals made occasionally for
them they don't want to put them in
nursing homes not because of the cost
but because it's a matter of dignity
they want to stay in their homes
but it's
hard you're just looking for an answer
so your parents can keep living
independently with dignity
for millions of families in america this
this issue is the most important issue
they're facing
it's personal
so here's what we're going to do
we're going to expand services for
seniors
so families can get help from
well-trained well-paid professionals
help them take care of their parents at
home
to cook meals for them
to get their groceries for them
help them get around
help them live in their own home
with the dignity they deserve to be
afforded
quite frankly
what we found is that this is more
popular or as popular as anything else
we're proposing
because the american people understand
the need
it's a matter of dignity and pride for
our parents
thirty years ago
we ranked number seven among the
advanced economies in the world
as a share of women working
now we are today
ranked 23rd
23rd
7-23
once again our competitors are investing
and we're standing still
today there are nearly 2 million women
in america
not working today simply because they
can't afford child care
typical family spends about 11 000 a
year on child care some states it's 14
500 a year per child
we're going to make sure
nearly all families earning less than
300 000 a year will pay no more than
seven percent of their income for child
care
and for a family making a hundred
thousand dollars a year
that will save them more than five
thousand dollars on child care
this is a fundamental game changer for
families
and for our economy
as more parents especially women can get
back to work and work in the workforce
i'm looking a lot of
significant press people in front of me
a lot of them are working working
mothers
they know what it costs
i remember when i got to the senate
i lost my wife and daughter in an
accident my two boys
i started commuting 250 miles a day
because i had my mom and my dad and my
brother and my sister
to help me take care of my kids because
i couldn't afford child care and i was
getting a serious salary 42 000 a year
we've also extended historic middle
class tax cut that's what i call a
middle
tax cut for parents
that is the expanded child tax credit we
pass through the american rescue plan
what that means is for folks at home
they're getting 300 a month for every
child under the age of six
250 dollars for every child under the
age of 18. we're extending that
the money is already a life changer for
so many working families
this will help cut child poverty in half
this year according to experts
but that's not all it does
it changes the whole dynamic for working
parents in the past
if you paid taxes and had a good income
you could deduct under the tax code two
thousand dollars per child
from the taxes you owed
but how many families do you know
a cashier waiters health care workers
who never got the benefit of the full
tax credit because they didn't have that
much to deduct
and it wasn't refundable
so it either came off your tax bill
or you didn't get full credit
why should if somebody making 500 000 a
year 150 000 or 200 000 a year get to
write it off their taxes
and the people who need to help even
more
they don't have that much tax to pay
they don't get the benefit and they have
the same cost of raising their children
eighty percent of those left out were
working parents who just didn't make
enough money
that's why in the american rescue plan
we didn't just expand the amount
of the middle class tax cut we also made
it refundable
this framework will make it permanently
refundable
making sure that the families who need
it get a full credit for it in addition
to those who are already getting full
credit
they're going to make sure that every
three and four-year-old child in america
go to high quality preschool
that's part of the legislation i just
brought up to the congress
studies show
that when we put three and four years
old in school
school not daycare school we increase by
up to 47 percent
the chance that that child no matter
what their background
will be able to earn a college degree
my wife jill is in the back here we
always says any country that out
educates us is going to out compete us
we can finally take us from 12 years to
14 years of universal education in
america
we also make investments in higher
education
by increasing pell grants to help
students from lower income families
attend community colleges and four-year
schools
and we invest in historically backed
universities colleges universities hbcus
minority serving institutions and tribal
colleges
to make sure every young student has a
shot at a good paying job of the future
this framework extends tax credits
to lower premiums for folks
on a fun who are in the affordable care
act for another three years
for four million from four million folks
in the 12 states that haven't expanded
medicaid all the rest have
this framework will enable you to get
affordable coverage
and medicare will now cover the cost of
hearing aids
and hearing checkups
this framework also makes the most
significant investment to deal with the
climate crisis ever ever happened
beyond any other advanced nation in the
world
over a billion metric tons of emission
reductions
at least 10 times bigger on climate than
any bill that has ever passed before and
enough to position us for a 50 to 52
emission reductions by the year 2030
and we'll do it in ways that grow the
domestic industries create good paying
union jobs
address long-standing environmental
injustices as well
tax credits help people do things like
weatherize their homes so they lose less
energy
install solar panels and develop clean
energy products
and help business produce more clean
energy
and when paired with the bipartisan
infrastructure bill
will truly transform this nation
historic investments in passenger rail i
know everybody says oh biden's a real
guy that's true
but passenger rail on freight rail and
public transit
it's going to make hundreds of thousands
take hundreds of thousands of vehicles
off the road
saving millions of barrels of oil
everybody knows all the studies show if
you can get from point a to point b on
electric rail
you won't drive your car
so take the rail service
we also learned that the most major
cities in america
minority populations the jobs they used
to have in town they're now out of town
roughly 60 percent of the folks they
don't have vehicles so they need to have
a means to get out of town to their jobs
to be on time
that's what this will do that like it
did for detroit
95
of the 840 000 school buses in america
run on diesel
every day more than 25 million children
and thousands of bus drivers
breathe polluted air on the way to and
from school from the diesel exhaust
we're going to replace thousands of
these with electric school buses
that have big batteries underneath it
and they'll they're good for the climate
i went down to the one one of the
manufacturing fields they saw them got
in one drive they do not expend any
they they don't expend any pollution
into the air
we'll build out the first ever national
network of 500 000 electric vehicle
charging stations all across the country
so when you buy an electric vehicle and
you get credit for buy-in you buy
electric vehicle you go all the way
across america on a single tank of gas
figuratively speaking it's not gas
you plug it in
500 000 of them
these stations along the way
we're going to get off the sidelines on
manufacturing solar panels and wind
farms and electric vehicles
with targeted manufacturing credits you
manufacture you get them a credit for
doing it
these will help grow the supply chains
in communities too often left behind and
we're going to reward countries for
paying good wages
for companies i should say for good
wages
and for sourcing the materials from here
in the united states
that means tens of millions of panels
and turbines
doubling the number of electric vehicles
we have on the road within just three
years
we'll be able to sell and export these
products and technologies to the rest of
the world and creating thousands more
jobs because we are once again going to
be the innovators
we'll also make historic investments in
environmental cleanup and remediation
that means putting people to work in
good paying jobs at prevailing wage
capping hundreds of thousands
hundreds of thousands of abandoned wells
in gas wells oil and gas wells that need
to be capped because they are leaking
things that hurt the air
putting a stop to the methane leaks
than the pipelines protecting the health
of our communities
it's a big deal
and we'll build up our resilience for
the next super storm drought wildfires
and hurricanes
that represent a blinking code red
for america in the world
last year alone
these types of extreme weather events
you've all been covering and you've all
witnessed and you've some of you been
caught in the middle of
have caused 99
billion
dollars in damage to the united states
within the last year 99 billion dollars
we're not spending any money to deal
with this
those power lines in the middle of storm
to try to put transformers in to keep
the lights on stormship
he calls himself 100 union guy
his job's dangerous
as he said
i quote
i don't want my kids growing up in a
world where the threat of climate change
hangs over their heads end of quote
folks
we all had that obligation
an obligation to our children and to our
grandchildren
the bipartisan infrastructure bill is
also the most significant investment
since we built the interstate highway
system
and won the space race decades ago
this is about rebuilding the arteries of
our economy
across the country now
there are 45 000 bridges
and 173 miles of thousand miles of roads
that are in poor condition
some of the bridges you don't even take
a chance of going across they shut
down it can't be built back to the same
standard
because the weather's not going to get a
lot better we just got to keep from
getting a heck of a lot worse
we have to build back better and
stronger
no one should have to hold their breath
as i cross a run-down bridge or a
dangerous intersection in their hometown
we're going to put hard-working
americans on the job to bring our
infrastructure up to speed
good union jobs and prevailing wages
jobs you can raise the family on my dad
would say you have a little breathing
room
jobs that can't be outsourced
jobs replacing lead water pipes
so families can drink clean water
improving the health of our children and
putting plumbers and pipe fitters to
work
jobs laying thousands of miles of
transmission lines to build a modern
energy grid
jobs making a high-speed internet
affordable and available everywhere in
rural and urban america
particularly including a 35 percent of
rural america that goes without it right
now
this pandemic has made clear the need
for affordable and available high-speed
internet
the idea
of a parent having to put their kids in
the car for virtual learning
drive and sit in the mcdonald's parking
lot
so the child can access the internet
when school is taught virtually
it's not only unnecessary it's just
wrong
it's wrong
as i said before these plans are
fiscally responsible
they are fully paid for
they don't add a single penny to the
deficit
they don't raise taxes on anyone making
less than
hundred thousand dollars a year
in fact they reduced the deficit here's
how
i don't want to punish anyone's success
i'm a capitalist
i want everyone to be able to if they
want to be a millionaire billionaire to
be able to seek their goal
but all i'm asking is
pay your fair share
pay your fair share
pay your fair share
and right now
many of you are paying virtually nothing
last year
the 55 most profitable corporations in
america 55 of them paid zero
zero
in federal income tax
on about 40 billion dollars in profit
if they report big profits to their
shareholders
they should be paying taxes it's that
simple
that's why the billback better framework
will have a 15 percent minimum
on the largest corporations a minimum
tax of 15 percent
the top 1 percent of the wealthiest
americans evade is estimated by the
experts
billion a year in federal taxes
that's wrong
we're going to change that
i want to emphasize what i said from the
beginning
under my plans if you earn less than 400
000 you won't pay a single penny more in
federal taxes period
in fact these bills continue cutting
taxes for middle class
for child care for health care so much
more
let me close with this
for much too long
working people of this nation
and the middle class of this country
have been dealt out of the american deal
it's time to deal them back in
[Music]
i ran for president saying it was time
to reduce
the burden on the middle class to
rebuild the backbone of this nation
working people and the middle class
i couldn't have been any clearer
from the very moment i announced my
candidacy
that's why i wrote these bills in the
first place and took them to the people
i campaigned on them
and the american people spoke
this agenda
the agenda that's in these bills is what
81 million americans voted for
more people voted than any time in
american history
that's what they voted for
their voices deserve to be heard not
denied
or worse ignored
because here's what i know
if we make these investments there will
be no stopping the american people or
america
we will own the future
i've long said it's never been a good
bet to bet against the american people
i've said that to foreign leaders as
well as everyone here in this country
which means it's always a good bet to
bet any american people
just give them half a chance
and that's what we're doing
that's what these plans do
they're about betting on america
about believing in america about
believing in the capacity of the
american people
if you look at the history of the
journey of this nation
what becomes crystal clear is this
i'll say it again
given half a chance
the american people have never ever ever
ever let the country down
so let's get this done
god bless you all and may god protect
your troops and i'll see you in
italy and in
that's uh the u.s president joe biden
standing alongside him was the vice
president kamala harris and they're off
after announcing a framework for an
agreement on his domestic spending
policy package the u.s president
said that they've reached the historic
economic framework on that spending bill
that includes historic investments in
the country he also said that people
will help reduce the deficit let's bring
in alan fisher for more details on what
the president uh just had to say alan
for anyone catching up with the news
just talk us through what we've heard
right now from the president
well essentially he's saying he has a
framework for his build back better
agenda which essentially will invest
billions of dollars in the us
infrastructure billions of dollars in
combating climate change and also
billions of dollars in social programs
it will do things like provide better
healthcare for the elderly better
preschool for young children ages in
three and four it will expand the child
tax credit uh for another couple of
years so that families who have children
under the age of 18 will get at least
250 dollars
from the government
he's been talking about this for months
there have been negotiations for months
and we're not talking about negotiations
between the democrats and the
republicans this is between democrats
and democrats and various wings of the
democratic party certainly the
progressives as they're known would like
to see a lot more in the bill such as
paid family leave that isn't going to
happen they would like to see a lot more
covered by medicaid that isn't going to
happen so they've got some things that
they did want though and the price tag
has come down from 3.5 trillion to 1.7
trillion still a lot of money and still
a lot of things that you can do with it
uh joe biden has been on the hill he's
been talking to members of the house
urging them to get behind this because
it's got to get through the house first
of all and then they think they have
enough votes to get through the senate
that is where most of the negotiations
have been to democratic senators who
have been holding out for things that
they want to see and things they won't
remove sorry about the noise that's the
helicopter just landing to take joe
biden off to the airport to fly to rome
for his meeting with the pope
so a lot of the things he's talked about
before he now believes that is the
framework of a deal
the difficulty of course is making sure
that that happens that bringing all
sides together making sure there are no
last-minute defections and deliver him
the political will when he wanted and
deliver the win he wanted before he
heads off to rome and the g7
okay alan we'll let you up for now thank
you so much alan fisher reporting from
the white house let's continue the
conversation with with jason nichols
he's a democratic strategist joining us
by skype from ellicott city in maryland
over in the u.s thanks for your time um
you were listening to the president just
give me your initial reaction to what
you just heard or are you pleased with
what joe biden had to say
i am i'm pleased with what joe biden had
to say i just wish she had said it
earlier because i think that there are
many americans who didn't understand
what was in buildback better and i don't
think he sold it enough to the american
people i think had he gone out there and
said the things that many americans
support like expanding medicare uh to
cover
vision and dental and hearing you know
84 of americans support that 67 percent
support universal pre-k
but there were many americans who did
not understand
uh that bill back better had these
things in it what they heard
was the republican talking point of the
price tag which by the way
was 3.5 trillion dollars it's down down
to 1.7 as allen pointed out but that's
over 10 years so that's not immediately
1.7 trillion dollars and as the
president pointed out today
it can be paid for if billionaires pay
their fair share if corporations pay
their fair share so i just wish he had
said these things earlier and
articulated it
earlier to the american people what
about some of the issues that had to be
compromised on and in fact this is
something that joe biden said just a few
moments ago he said
no one got everything that they wanted
but it was a compromise
well that's why i think he was correct
and that's why the american people
selected him over somebody like bernie
sanders uh i think they thought of him
as someone who was going to bring people
together bring sides together and uh be
willing to bend in order to get an
overall win for the american people and
i think that's what it looks like
happened here
in negotiating with senator cinema and
senator manchin so
that's what he was selected for and the
things that were taken out are very
important but i think the message to
democrats should be
that
if you want these things you have to go
out and vote and get democrats elected
if they have a bigger majority in all of
these uh houses whether it's the senate
or the house
or the senate and the house i should say
you will be able to get more of what you
want and there are plenty of house and
senate seats open well all of the house
seats just about are open but the uh the
senate has places like pennsylvania
north carolina and ohio that are
winnable seats so democrats have to go
out and vote and we can get things like
paid family leave which by the way
is very popular with the american people
with independence with democrats uh 73
percent of americans according to some
polls support paid family leave so this
is something that was had that had to be
taken out in order to make a deal but i
don't think it's gone forever and i
think if democrats go out and vote they
can make this happen okay jason nichols
thanks so much for sticking around we
appreciate your time thank you
thank you